[Music]
I'm remiss to say this but mm says his
mom white light
mm sends his mom's spaghetti pasta to
Detroit health care workers on the
corona virus from we had like his mom no
he did this spaghetti have some type of
things to keep people sick so you know
the story that's really good
that was really under inside baseball
right there good really I'm so okay so
his mom used to keep him sick because
she loved by proxy
right so it's kind of like when you
coddle your kids and you're just like oh
you're so sick I need to save you so I'm
gonna feed you poison so that you stay
oh yeah that's what he attributes to him
being into the pills yeah because his
mom used to do that to him yeah is that
what she's doing keeping them safe no no
no that was a joke I threw in because
she's feeding him spaghetti but now yet
he came from his 8 mile movie if you
remember the songs yourself she's
nervous because she keeps on calm and
ready John held it healthcare workers in
Detroit lost themselves in spaghetti in
a spaghetti controvert I know that
oh just explain it cuz I'm so confused
lose yourself is this song no no no he
said pasta to the people badmouth Verona
virus on the front lines like hospitals
are stuffing his mom's pasta kind of a
me actually so he actually said food
yeah and then said spaghetti though
specifically and also to feed healthcare
work is it really his mom's spaghetti
cuz I didn't know she was still alive no
rum moms rest he doesn't really talk to
her that's how song
just very sick we're in this together so
he wraps you it's my mom's recipe no no
it's not even my mama it's just she's
donating guys okay let me like him yeah
so how does the song go to Nadine take
it done and my mom's recipe recipe very
good spaghetti it's on spaghetti broke
down the spaghetti ain't down take it
Nelson have you had Tabasco on spaghetti
it's pretty [ __ ] bow everything Papa
John basil
Tabasco too low which one's better huh
depends on when you're you're not using
Cholula that's very true by the way do
you think that I feel what I feel that
was a real difference of course the
Vivier base of Tabasco fills your
nostrils as it fills your entire living
room as Steve is cooking he makes it in
the [ __ ] pan so like the sphere
coffee oh my god so knows I missed
attacked by it I will open the front
door I'm like oh my god what did I walk
into the vinegar is strong very strong
shouldn't do that when she sucks my dick
spill okay why do you put the vinegar on
your dick it's very clean it's good I
want you to I want you guys to try this
at home is do half sriracha and half
white vinegar it is [ __ ] sounds good
the best oh and if you pour it on front
you just gave away your secret sauce you
could have [ __ ] made a Jamali and
sauce bro this spice off better
it's imagine the vinegary of Tabasco
it's a little bit sweet from that
vinegar and it's got the same type of
sriracha anus of it I'll [ __ ] with it I
love sriracha okay however in 2017
eminem opened a mom spaghetti pop up at
the shelter downtown detroit where he
encouraged people to come vomit up some
spaghetti oh no oh wait what the [ __ ]
mommy is in the song don't move vomit on
his sweater already mom's spaghetti he's
nervous
you know people with eating disorders to
come and eat and have a vomit party oh
no it's joke back off sorry Michael
Jackson touched people in their heart
that's pretty much to all of us in the
heart touched me
obviously Michigan's one of the state's
hit hit hit hard hardest by the covin so
MN doing that's kind of nice
do you think he still lives in the
Detroit the DiBiase but it's like on a
mansion on a hill what you think okay
what you thinkin latest album a [ __ ]
love did yes part I love it I didn't
like it fine listening to it well you
didn't like it
music to be murdered by mmm-hmm you want
like beat it sucked
Wow beat it completely suck did no a day
no one wants to be defeated what kind of
[ __ ] rhyme is that [ __ ] the music
video was pretty sick to have a sausage
actually I'm not clowning on his
classics his new stuff is something
happened that's all I'm saying something
happened to you think out you're a
tourist what do you think happen
you lost his edge did he get work done
on his face because it looks yes he has
and he raps about it what he got he got
Botox well I mean he raps about how like
people see notice his crow's feet and
him getting older and like he also was
self-conscious in the mirror about yeah
cuz he because it's not pretty is that a
feminine thing to do no no but some
surgery it's probably Michael Jackson oh
no he's natural vitiligo yeah it was a
medical condition so that made him nose
like that yeah do you make fun of people
with challenges in their lives like that
any waking up [ __ ]
it was a medical condition his life yeah
as a medical condition - so wait is it
but-but-but exactly what it means I was
like vanity to me I want to know and
this might be even why I selected this
article was to find out your take on is
that feminine if Eminem gets hypocrite
Oh was he here's the thing I don't want
to [ __ ] him in him so it doesn't really
matter what any one book for you yeah I
really don't want to [ __ ] anybody but
Steve but Eminem was my idol and not
just I know that you maybe you can't
understand this not a superficial way
but actually the lyrics that he talks
about in his art that I really enjoy
listening to so uh yeah maybe he's
guided me as a lonely child like he
talks he speaks to lonely kids
everywhere and says that you know this
song is for you and maybe I take it and
I'm like this song is for me and I
really believe that crow's feet the
crow's feet on his feet my crow's feet
if Eminem was a white biggie do you
think you would like him as much sure
because you think it was it was an
overweight they did you not see him
during his fat stage
he was a fat stage INFs even a boy was
like I think he's pretty large I don't I
don't care how anyone looks if they
sound like [ __ ] of the music's batter
won't listen to it so what do you think
of Eminem I like him in him I really I
do too okay we can be friends for good
good I'm just I'm just glad to become
your friends but I missed his hair when
it was kind of like a bolshie that's not
mm I missed that I like Slim Shady
because the sun shade LP was my favorite
that's it does bass that's the most
[ __ ] basic shade you realize that
that's so commercial Wow
Steve when did you change bro bro that's
what I always thought my era of
that was the whole my era my era my air
was so original did he say that oh yeah
I would assume so
what was that when he joined with the
other group d12
he's $12 I was like my [ __ ] was like
mine with him he co-founded there I was
like to see 12 months to when you were 2
and then when you had a song my salsa
dude it's called my band but whatever
you know you know what was so weird
out of d12 though was the game like he
was always the odd one out and I'm like
why is he a part of it and obviously he
broke up from the group and did his own
thing but I was like I thought d12 was
his like boys it was the Dirty Dozen it
was but the game is a West Coast guy the
game the guy I don't think the game was
ever d12 no no wait so was it yeah mm
got big and then he did d12 and he went
out again yeah he was trying to intro
okay so so d12 is like his homies they
came up with RJ and so after he blew up
he tried to raise use his soul he was
g-unit my bad of it to rate yes cute it
he says he like in every right anything
that like he'd they're connected in a
way we found it's he found City Sam yeah
did you do that's why the confusion yeah
yeah but d12 he couldn't get on the map
50 cent or dr. J fund so he discovered
Kurtis uppity son Jackson if you recall
he was on the 8 mile soundtrack and I
was with him all first discovering music
and people claim that they have to suck
dr. J's dick wait what happened that
conspiracy is that the rappers that work
with the dr. J in order for them to
become successful they have to suck cess
dr. Dre yeah he said Eminem and dr. Dre
had like a little love affair that's
what they rap about that like they were
I have a love affair we rap about being
gay together wait what yeah that's why
it's what it was funny in the movie the
interview where Eminem talks about being
gay and then he's like I love clues
everywhere
oh this a joke it's not real yeah it's
yeah that's what he's been called
homophobic because he makes gay jokes
about him being gay and so people are
like he's homophobic and then everyone
in rap is hopeful and John did a song
with him like he's not [ __ ]
homophobic shut up dude camel the wins
most homophobic song I ever heard
that's all in Jon's home well was that
one song with oh it's his name it was
called Yonkers I think or what Saul the
guy he eats a cockroach in the music
video you talk about Bruno Martins
is a f-word in a closet he's a really
popular rapper right now how the credit
he's crazy
super but then he's he's gay yeah she's
a super troll I believe so yeah her name
called Tyler and call it aside to create
it was gay in a song and I got Scott
flack for that dude can you feel the
love that is super on these it offensive
if you call a gay person gay no why
derogatory warm anything is well you
can't see as a pejorative
oh yeah that's like if I called you like
that occasion or something hey yeah but
you don't call Asians you Asians well I
do if I want you to go home but if you
don't you know but you don't say like
hey this is Johnny he's a gay user gays
no I don't think you say no yeah but
he's like oh he's gay that's awkward
that's fine why are you bringing up out
of nowhere there's people hey some
people do that it would be like there's
my gay friend John have you ever seen
the movie ghostbusters with Rick Moranis
yes where he walks through the party he
introduces everybody he tells them their
entire financial situation and their tax
situation like that hey he's gay he's
had sex with guys was so big he put it
across the college anyway it's nice to
meet you okay see you guys later
like it's like that I don't know growing
up it was maybe there's just a lot of
white people they just didn't know they
were always super nice and everything
but they'll us and the D means Afghan
but when I talk to my friends are just
oh this is Tim that's it yeah like
you're a rarity that's why see I think
that so coming boy matches article and
you know sorry ball is um that's the mm
is a good boy he was so-so
so sweet so thoughtful he loves his
community and he supports it all the
time and he gets a bad rap just like you
get a bad rap where like where people
think you're an [ __ ] but really
you're just a huge [ __ ] softie I've
already talked about but I will say what
the [ __ ] is a vagabond if that's not how
we just look we just learned this word
on the circle it came up and the circle
and I was like that's what that word
means kings and vagabonds that is
[ __ ] homes like that but that was a
online King okay
it's or something I've got I was a gypsy
that's what I always think I thought it
was a slur that's like a god oh well we
do have a computer be a king when you
could be a bad bag a bond would you go
a person who wanders from place to place
without a homer job sounds like a
homeless it sounds like somebody who
doesn't know what sex you're out of here
I have to jump on the on the train with
with a sack with on a stick
yeah vagabond having no settled home I'm
dating sexual home
[Music]
you